got the crickets I think this is pretty
much the grossest thing I've ever had to
cook with but haven't won yet well he
did win that challenge two-time James
Beard Award winner Hugh Acheson is a
familiar face to Top Chef fans this
morning we uncover a different side of
the man many know as the sarcastic chef
of the South tracking at Jason's journey
from the kitchens of Canada to Athens
and Atlanta Georgia in a special
Christmas edition of the dish when you
start working in kitchens at age 15 you
get pretty comfortable as a celebrity
chef Hugh Acheson sees with cutlery and
camera crews is pretty much on par can
you make her up just kind of pull out as
you're tightening just a little bit and
that'll form the circle more it doesn't
want to cooperate I know it's not
cooperating you guys are going to be
editing this AHA yeah we're building
something he's building a crown of lamb
something he does each December as the
centerpiece of his family's Christmas
Eve dish now I wouldn't eat this much
butter every day but you might as well
so now this is gonna go into an oven
down there at 350 do you find when you
eat something like that that has so many
memories can you feel like you're back
in time I think the most memorable meals
of your life always hold a heart string
of familiarity of something you've
experienced before and I think holiday
dinners are really important to kind of
ground us all you can go out for
Szechuan food on Christmas night and if
that's your tradition so be it that's
great I will say it it is my that is my
Jewish Christmas Eve that's what it is
but that's the holidays the holidays is
that memories and the repetition of
and comfort of things that bring you all
together that's traditions and so keep
on doing it Addison still remembers the
more everyday food he ate growing up in
Ottawa Canada we had one of the first
microwaves my dad would take a corn
squash cut it in half and put a pad of
butter and real Canadian maple syrup and
get it in the microwave and it's the
best thing ever and then we have a
little poached chicken next to it and
that was dinner it's simple have you
done it really sick I mean I do it all
the time
when you were eating a meal like that
with your dad would you have ever
envisioned this and what you've become
I'm planning this for nearly 30 years
Addison worked in kitchens in Ottawa
Montreal and San Francisco before
settling in Athens Georgia home to the
rock band REM and the University of
Georgia in 2000 he opened five and ten
the first of two Athens restaurants a
decade later he expanded to Atlanta with
Empire State south and in October at
jusen opened by George inside the
Candler hotel downtown ASA
built this building as kind of an homage
to himself coca-cola magnate ASA Candler
built the 17 floor building once the
tallest in the city in 1906 it's funny
you go in the staircases and you see
like Rembrandt Socrates and it's a
Candler solid marble all the way through
and these chandeliers and things like
that
Addison named his restaurant after the
buildings to architects both named
George I mean that's the Tiffany windows
when they're not alone the building
which was last home to a bank features
the original brass elevator doors in the
lobby downstairs at Jason's kitchen sits
next to the old safe the 3,000 square
foot restaurant which sits below got its
identity from the kitchens of Acheson z'
youth I'd always wanted to do a French
restaurant I'm fluent in French it's
what I was trained in and so I feel a
pedigree or a background
worthy of that to clean that his latest
cookbook sous-vide is a nod to the
French immersion method of cooking food
in a low-temperature bath
sous-vide like at Jason's previous
cookbooks includes illustrations that he
prefers to call doodles where did that
start from you know I come from a this
family of really interesting academics
but my mother was an artist where my
sister's an artist it was never really a
skill set that I thought I had but it
was a good way of visualizing the food
that we do answer planning up menus and
then it became more whimsical it's just
fun do you do it for every meal that
you're gonna do every recipe or just
randomly it's more random than anything
but Acheson did doodle the menu for our
Christmas Eve dish this is literally
what you drew is now on the table yeah
pretty much
so you've got a Vidalia onion tart okay
a really simple savory Joe and it's
almost like a quiche for lack of a
better term
this is pommes Anna there's her classic
French dish of layered potatoes slowly
cooked in a big copper pan which is very
old-school our turnips that have got
their greens and then braised turnips
with in them a simple salad with
radishes and a classic French
vinaigrette that's a salsa feed gang
that's tastes like an oyster a long root
vegetable and then I've got the lamb
this to you is Christmas Eve this is
Christmas Eve pretty much every year you
know when I was young I was so bad I
would like find all my Christmas
presents wrap them and then I used them
and now I'll wrap them back up and stick
them on the tree nobody ever noticed I'm
just realizing there's one thing we have
not tried yet oh the booster Noel yeah
are you gonna go for that well you have
to right booster well is is this classic
roll cake Christmas Eve and Christmas
are all multi-generational - it's like
you're your aim is to make people happy
this is just so making my log I mean
it's chocolate and sugar anything good
so good Cheers
yeah thank you for making Thanks
you for coming here to Atlanta so they
can learn to by George all right Dana
you might have liked that you'll love I
was calm it's good to I gotta say he
said one thing he said you know food is
nourishment not just for your body but
for your soul and that's the emotion we
talked about I love that idea
that's a funny dude he's great a really
thoughtful dude too
you